hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game from round 10 of this
year's Tata still Masters Edition it is
Magnus Carlsen and going into round 10
both of them have already suffered two
losses uh interestingly both of them
lost to Abdul saturov uh and uh they
would very much enjoy grabbing a full
point in this game now Magnus uh he's uh
pretty much used to winning every
tournament and now he has recovered from
the two losses he also won two games he
will uh be looking for a way to take a
full point from Parham even though he
has the black pieces and that's why he
goes out of theory very very early on in
this game as early as move seven as
you'll see very soon so let's dive
straight into it Parham with the white
pieces opens with D4 we have D5 for
Magnus C4 we have E6 and now Knight to
C3 Knight F6 uh the Queen's Gambit
declined is on the board and we have the
exchange variation captures captures and
Bishop to G5 very popular the shop to E7
and Ponte E3 the so-called positional
line we have H6 Bishop to H4 and now uh
there are hundreds and hundreds of games
in the database where just castles
displayed here but Magnus goes Bishop to
G4 and there is only one game in the
database where this was played as the
White Queen is attacked uh Queen to a
for check was played in that game that's
weird Arrow but here we have Queen to B3
by Parham sorry Queen to B3 was played
but Parham goes Queen to a for check uh
and it is now as of move eight that we
have a completely new game so Magnus
blocks with Pawn to C6 and now Bishop to
D3 just continuing developing completely
ignoring magnus's Bishop on G4 we have
castles now uh and pawn to H3 Bishop to
H5 and queen back to C2 now putting
pressure on this long diagonal also uh
Bishop to G6 is no longer an option as
the Magnus uh Parham controls the G6
Square twice so here we have Pawn to C5
by Magnus attacking the center as
barham's king is still in the center of
the board but this also means he has to
sacrifice upon and Parham goes for that
pawn pawn to G4 we have C character
Sunday for E captures and D4 and Bishop
to G6 uh and that's why uh um Bishop
captress on G6 just wins a pawn or so
you would think F characters and G6
Queen captures on G6 and now Magnus
plays Knight captures on G4 uh seems
like a peace sacrifice but not really as
he's also attacking the undefended
bishop on H4 and now you could capture
the Knight or you could capture the
bishop or you could play Queen to E6
check the problem with Bishop captures
and on E7 is that Queen captures with
check and now once you block this also
Knight captures an F2 and Magnus is just
a very close to winning here so that's
why baham goes Queen to E6 with check
now the bishop is attacked twice so
rooked F7 blocking check uh we uh here
we have age captures on G4 you could
also consider a more like Knight to F3
to maybe add a Defender to the bishop or
Bishop back to G3 but Parham likes H
characters and G4 with Bishop captures
on H4 and Knight to F3 Now The Rook is
spin so no worries uh we have Queen to
F6 Magnus offers a trade and Parham
trades Queen captures Bishop captures
and now Knight captures on D5 so if you
consider everything it does seem that
Parham won a pawn here so what's
magnus's idea sacrificing a pawn like
this with the black pieces he goes
Knight to C6 now he puts pressure on the
D4 pawn and Rook to D1 Parham defense we
have Rook the E8 with check now uh
Knight back to E3 and now Rook to E4
just putting more pressure on uh White's
uh pawns here the the G4 Pawn is
attacking uh well it's defended by the
Knight but it's a very unpleasant
position to be in especially with the
King and E1 so here Pawn to D5 Parham
finds the best move and Magnus goes
Knight to B4 now looking to win back
some material the A2 Pawn is saying the
Dupont is saying also you have to worry
about Knight to C to check as the Knight
uneasari is pinned and Parham continues
very strong a pawn to D6 he just
advances his pass pawn and he wants to
win the game uh Knights the seat to
check by Magnus not going for any pawns
here we have King the E2 and now Knight
captures on E3 removing the defender of
the G4 Pawn so F captures an E3 and now
Rook captures on G4 and you have this
position where the material is even and
uh Parham should think very very hard
about what his next move will be and his
next move should be Pawn to D7 this is
the best way to play and then Magnus has
to block with Bishop to d8 and so on
there are many ways to continue the game
however he instead after Rook the G4
played The Rook to D5 probably with the
idea of trading of the uh the the the
Knight for Bishop going for this Fork
but Magnus doesn't allow it he plays
Rook to D7 and now this is pretty much
much pointless if you go Knight E5 now
then you just blunder the D6 Pawn so
instead I have to Rook to D7 Parham
plays Rook to F1 and here just B3 was
the better move just uh getting that
pawn out of Harm's Way but maybe he
thought okay then I run into some Rook
to G2 check action then maybe I have to
give up the A2 Pawn uh but not really
even if you go for the spawn to B3 and
Rook to G2 check uh just King to D3 and
the Magnus is not in time to claim the
da2 pawn if you play Rook captures on A2
then E4 then E5 then E6 and it will be
very hard to defend this
uh but okay I have to Rook the D7 Rook
the F1 was played uh but this is pretty
much a waste of time now Magnus just
gobbles up the B2 pawn bishop captures
on B2 and now we have Rook to D3
preparing to defend this Pawn with Ponte
A3 Bishop back to F6 and now comes Rook
to D5 uh some uh re-maneuvering of the
Rooks here by Parham uh but Magnus finds
the very strong Rook to B4 now he can
play Rook to B2 with check uh so Rook F
the D1 preparing to block check and save
his Pawn but now King to F7 we have Rook
one to D3 and the problem here for
Parham uh aside from him playing weird
Rook moves is that he is down to 30
seconds on the clock and Magnus has some
40 minutes on the clock and this is only
move 32 so you still need uh to make
eight moves to reach time control so
King to E6 the move that pretty much
seals the deal for for Magnus now the
the rook and is uh on D5 will be
attacked if this Rook moves and this
makes it very difficult for Parham to
actually defend Knight the D2 was played
now Rook to A4 attacks the A2 Pawn but
now A3 that was played in the game isn't
all that impressive Magna just captures
it Rook captures an A3 uh we have Rook
captures and King captures on D5 we have
Rook captures on A7 now King captures on
D6 and Magnus is up two full pawns and
he does have uh two connected pass pawns
on the king side and he has a pass Pawn
on the queen side so it will be
incredibly difficult for Parham to hold
this he goes 94 check King to D5 and he
even trades here Knight captures Pawn
captures and The Rook to A5 with check
King to C4 by Magnus and now Rook to F5
here with this move Rook to F5 uh Parham
reaches time control and he is now
granted additional time but uh it's not
not easy to play this and while Magnus
could continue with B5 uh he could give
up some pawns here and just start
advancing the pawn The Rook completely
cuts off the white king from uh
approaching that pawn he plays it safe
you know that doesn't spoil his
possession and also it doesn't require
him to calculate as much as sacrificing
the pawn with B5 right away so okay Rook
F4 check King to B3 we've Rook the F5
now uh hoping to get that check-in to
win the B7 Pawn but just King A4 we have
Rook to F for checking to A5 and now
Rook to H4 going after the H6 Pawn but
this is much much safer than giving up
the F Pawn so just Pawn to B5 uh Rook
captures an H6 Pawn to B4 uh usually a
winning move but so so it is in this
position as well Pawn to E4 and now you
have to decide between upon the B3 and
King to A4 both are winning but Magnus
chooses the move which requires um to be
less precise in calculating but I will
just show for fun that B3 is winning
point is that now I have to Rook to H1
you will play B2 and after Rook to B1
you can play Rook to B6 it looks weird
because the white king can also approach
the bee Pawn but after King D2 King A4
King C2 you have King A3 and now white
is uh without a move whatever you play
you just get destroyed if Rook to F1 you
can even resort to tricks like this uh
just a queen in Pawn to B1 Rook captures
Rook captures King captures now you box
in the white king you win the pawn and
that's of course a winning end game
completely King to the four king D2
captures captures but you don't care you
have the the past Pawn Pont five King F2
King F4 you have the opposition uh you
are winning this if white goes this way
you go this way if white goes this way
you go this way and then you start
pushing the pawn
uh so that's why uh B3 is also possible
Magnus decided to play King A4 first uh
we have Pawn to E5 now uh Parham finds
tricky ideas here Rook the E6 the only
winning a move for Magnus but not a
difficult one to spot Rook captures an
E6 Rook captures an E5 King to D1 but
now just Rook to C5 cutting off the
white king from reaching the B Pawn and
there's just not all that much to do
here but uh Parham decided to test the
magnus's end game skill and he continues
the game Rook to A6 check King to King
to B3 with Rook the D6 and now King to
A3 with rooked A6 check King to B2 and
now Rook back to D6 we have Pawn to B3
Rook to d8 and now King the B1 preparing
to further Advance the B Pawn King to D2
and now Pawn to B2 with rooked A8 and
now it seems like the black king is
completely boxed in there is no way to
get the the blacking out but Magnus
shows that he knows of course how to win
in this he plays Rook the D5 check and
he was in this position animal 56 that
Barham aksulu resigned to the game and
the Magnus gets another very nice
Victory which brings him um uh all the
way I believe the shared third place
with Wesley so now we have another uh
leading the tournament in Seoul first
place Anish in second place and the
Magnus sharing third with with Wesley so
uh we'll see uh we'll see what else
happens in the tournament Magnus still
has to play uh Wesley Prague and Arjun
so it's going to be a three incredible
rounds he's gonna have the white pieces
in in two of those rounds against the
Wesley and Prague so we'll see uh Prague
or you know can play a very mean game
against Magnus he can he already shown
that he can beat him in any time format
Wesley can beat anyone in any time
format and Arjun if you know on a good
day he has the white pieces against
Magnus uh it's definitely not going to
be easy but it seems Magnus has
recovered from the two consecutive
losses I will see if he uh if he's able
to overtake Wesley Anish NW satrov or
will uh Abdu satrov just continue
crushing it or will maybe a niche take
the tournament uh anything uh can still
happen but yeah a nice line by Magnus
here for those of you who are maybe new
to chess here you resign because after
you move the king let's say King to C3
uh just King C1 and there's no way uh
you stop the pawn you don't even have a
check and if you don't play King to C3
you could play King to E3 that will
allow you some checks via the C file but
it doesn't matter King to C2 let's say
Rook to see it with Chuck King to D1 now
Rook to B8 you stop queening but not a
problem Rook to D2 looks like a weird
move but it gets the job done Rook to B7
white keeps an eye on the B1 Square now
King to C1 we have Rook to B8 now you
still don't want a queen because white
will just capture and then gobble up the
rook and it will be a draw by
insufficient material so you're gonna
play Rook the C2 and now there's nothing
King D3 and now you bring your Pawn to
become a queen real Captain in
characters and now you Checkmate the
white king so that's that's pretty much
it uh Arjun uh sorry not Arjun Parham
tested Magnus the same game skill but
here he thought all right I believe you
know what uh what is to follow uh sure
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I'm gonna show the full standings after
I show at least one more game and I'm
pretty sure you guys know which one I'm
talking about
um so that's uh that's pretty much uh
that's pretty much it
uh uh and yeah I would like to thank
Blasio burkot Rob Victor David Peter
Canary and uh John Noonan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day